so I just came around the corner I found
this female on the beach here and I
thought I recognized she's the one of
one of the mothers as having come so I
was looking for the Cubs all up in the
forest here and there all of a sudden
it's like ah they're there and they're
right on this diagonal log here and the
bottom one is obviously got itch cause
he keeps grabbing a branch then going
that is amazing
these Cubs are gonna be brilliant
climbers that's how the female defends
them from male bears that want to kill
them they'll send the Cubs up a tree and
the Cubs can climb so high and really
really fast
their safe places is on the tree we're
just about to go to sleep and back at
home some crashing and said you hear
that bear and then I heard a noise that
I heard many times before it and it's
the noise that the mother makes to her
cubs so I immediately knew that they
were Cubs so we decided to cut out the
tent to find out that the tree literally
two feet from the front door ten had two
bear cubs up it okay let's just back up
second oh ok sorry guys you know
sorry guys we're going to get another
way and you can go back to mama okay
sorry
headphones down don't mind us pretty
amazing experience and another reminder
how much of a wild place this is very
cool so there's the bear cub who's
decided to climb a tree and here is our
tent and mums coming together okay there
we go
both let's go those who still want that
note to store
okay Daniel just go down the trail all
the way down good there you go that's
one angry little bear cub how funny is
that of all the trees okay bye-bye one
of our team members launches a drone and
all the sudden bear started charging
alan runs out and grabs the drone like
that's important at this point